>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD."
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
WE START WITH OUR MONEY LEAD.
MORE CRUSHING ECONOMIC NEWS FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THIS
AFTERNOON.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE ANNOUNCED
ANOTHER MASSIVE INTEREST RATE
HIKE.
THREE-QUARTERS OF A PERCENTAGE
POINT.
A MOVE THAT SEEMED UNFATHOMABLE
TO MANY HAS HAPPENED TWICE IN A
ROW.
THE INCREASE TRANSLATES TO
AMERICANS PAYING MORE MONEY FOR
THINGS SUCH AS MORTGAGE LOANS,
CAR LOANS, STUDENT LOANS.
TODAY'S HIKE, OF COURSE, WAS NOT
UNEXPECTED.
FEIGN IN FACT, JEROME POWELL
HINTED AT IT LAST MONTH AND SAID
IT'S THE BEST WAY TO COOL DOWN
INFLATION, BUT THAT TAKES TIME
AND IT WILL PROVIDE NO IMMEDIATE
HELP FOR AMERICANS STRUGGLING
WITH HIGHER PRICES ON CLOTHES
AND GROCERIES AND ENERGY BILLS.
MATT EGAN, WHY DOES THE FED
THINK MAKING AMERICANS PAY
HIGHER INTEREST RATES WILL HELP
THE ECONOMY?
>> WELL, JAKE, NO DOUBT, THIS IS
SOME TOUGH MEDICINE FROM THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE AMERICANS
DEALING WITH THE WORST INFLATION
IN FOUR YEARS, BUT NOW THEY'RE
GETTING SQUEEZED BY SOARING
BORROWING KAUS.
CREDIT CARDS, STUDENT DEBT, CAR
LOANS, APPLIANCES, AND OF
COURSE, MORTGAGES.
IN FACT, THE SPIKE IN MORTGAGE
RATES IS ALREADY SLOWING DOWN
THE HOUSING MARKET.
BUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT HERE IS
THIS IS A FEATURE, NOT A BUG OF
THE FED POLICY.
THEY'RE TRYING TO COOL OFF RED
HOT DEMAND, IN THE HOPES THAT
IT'S GOING TO GIVE TIME FOR
SUPPLY TO CATCH UP.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THAT IF THEY
DO TOO MUCH, THEY'RE GOING TO
FREEZE THIS ECONOMY AND CAUSE A
RECESSION.
AND THIS IS NOT AN EXACT
SCIENCE, JAKE.
THEY WON'T KNOW THEY HAVE GONE
TOO FAR UNTIL IT'S TOO LATE.
>> WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
CHANCES OF A RECESSION?
>> WELL, THE FACT THAT THE
FEDERAL RESERVE IS MOVING SO
AGGRESSIVELY TO RAISE INTEREST
RATES DOES MAKE THIS A DANGEROUS
MOMENT FOR THE ECONOMY.
THIS WAS NOT THE PLAN.
THEY PREFERRED TO JUST TAP THE
BRAKES ON THE ECONOMY.
JUST GRADUALLY RAISE THE
INTEREST RATES, BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT OPTION BECAUSE
INFLATION KEEPS GETTING WORSE
AND THEY WERE LATE TO THIS
INFLATION CRISIS.
AND SO THEY HAVE TO SLAM THE
BRAKES.
POWELL ADDRESSED THIS QUESTION
HEAD ON TODAY DURING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
FIRST HE SAID HE DOES NOT
BELIEVE THE U.S. ECONOMY IS
CURRENTLY IN RECESSION.
HE SAID THE JOBS MARKET IS WAY
TOO STRONG FOR THIS TO BE A
RECESSION.
SECONDLY, HE SAYS HE THINKS
THERE IS STILL A PATH TO GET
INFLATION UNDER CONTROL WITHOUT
CAUSING A RECESSION, THOUGH
JAKE, HE CONCEDED THAT PATH HAS
GOTTEN NARROWER.
>> IS THERE A CHANCE THAT THE
FEDERAL RESERVE WILL RAISE RATES
AGAIN NEXT MONTH IN SEPTEMBER?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY, THERE IS A
VERY GOOD CHANCE THEY RAISE
RATES IN SEPTEMBER.
MARKETS ARE ANTICIPATING IT, THE
FED STATEMENT HINTED AT IT, THE
CHAIRMAN SIGNALED THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
THE BIG QUESTION IS HOW MUCH DO
THEY RAISE INTEREST RATES BY.
POWELL SAID THEY WOULDN'T
HESITATE TO DO AN EVEN BIGGER
RATE HIKE IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
THOUGHT WAS NECESSARILY, HE HE
LEFT OPEN THE POSSIBILITY THEY
SLOW DOWN HIKES.
THE NEXT MEETING ISN'T FOR EIGHT
WEEKS SO A LOT IS GOING TO
DEPEND ON WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
ECONOMY.
>> MATT EGAN, THANKS SO MUCH.
>> TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT IS
ANOTHER BODY BLOW TO STRUGGLING
AMERICANS.
ONE NONPROFIT SAYS HE'S RECEIVED
NEARLY DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
CALLS OF PEOPLE ASKING FOR HELP.
GABE COHEN SPOKE TO CITIZENS
ABOUT THE IMPACTS THESE RATE
HIKES ARE HAVING ON THEIR LIVES.
>> THANKS TO INTEREST RATES,
SUPORA IS HOUSE HUNTING IN D.C.
WITH DEFLATED EXPECTATIONS.
>> I STARTED LOOKING AT HOUSES
IN THE $500, $550 RANGE, AND
ENDED UP COMING DOWN TO ABOUT
$380, MAYBE $450 AS A HARD STOP.
>> BECAUSE OF MORTGAGES.
>> BECAUSE OF THE MORTGAGE
RATES.
>> MORTGAGE PAYMENTS ON A
TYPICAL U.S. HOME ARE UP 62% IN
A YEAR.
COSTING AMERICANS HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS MORE EACH MONTH.
AND THEY'LL LIKELY KEEP RISING
AS THE FEDERAL RESERVE RAISES
INTEREST RATES.
>> SOME PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT TO
WAIT UNTIL THE WRECKAGE IS DONE.
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE THIS LARGE
INTEREST RATE LOOMING OVER ME.
>> THE FED'S LATEST RATE HIKE
COULD DRIVE UP THE COST OF CAR
LOANS AND CREDIT CARD DEBT TOO.
AMERICANS OWED $840 BILLION IN
OUTSTANDING CREDIT AT THE START
OF 2022.
>> IT SNEAKS UP ON YOU.
>> GARY HERMAN RUNS CONSOLIDATED
CREDIT SOLUTIONS, A NONPROFIT
THAT HELPS PEOPLE SOLVE DEBT
PROBLEMS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN A DRAMATIC
INCREASE, ALMOST DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF NEW PEOPLE CALLING OUR
OFFICE LOOKING FOR HELP WITH
CREDIT CARD DEBT, AND THAT'S
JUST BEEN IN THE PAST TWO
MONTHS.
>> THE FED'S RATE HIKE AIMS TO
COOL THIS 40-YEAR HIGH
INFLATION.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO DO JUST THE
RIGHT AMOUNT.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO HAVE A
RECESSION.
>> IN THE SHORT TERM, IT'S ONE
MORE STRAIN ON AMERICANS.
>> WE'RE IN A REALLY CRAZY TIME
RIGHT NOW.
>> CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS DOWN
FOR THE THIRD STRAIGHT MONTH.
AND ACCORDING TO ONE POLL, 65%
OF AMERICAN VOTERS THINK WE'RE
ALREADY IN A RECESSION.
>> I HAVE NOTICED GAS HAS GONE
DOWN, BUT GROCERIES STILL HAVE
NOT GONE DOWN.
FRUITS, VEGETABLES KEEP GOING
UP.
I'M PRETTY CONCERNED.
>> NICOLAS KEEPS TIGHTENING HIS
BUDGET IN ATLANTA.
>> WE'RE HAVING TO CULT BACK A
LOT JUST TO GET BY.
>> IN A SURVEY BY MORGAN
STANLEY, TWO-THIRDS OF U.S.
CONSUMERS SAY THEY'RE PLANNING
TO REDUCE SPENDING IN THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS, ESPECIALLY ON BIG
TICKET ITEMS LIKE HOME
APPLIANCES AND CARS.
ROB SHANE'S CLUNKER HAS NO AIR
CONDITIONING AND A VIOLENT
SHAKE, NEEDING $7,000 OF
REPAIRS.
>> THE MECHANIC TOLD US WE
SHOULDN'T DRIVE IT ANY FURTHER
THAN WE'RE COMFORTABLE WALKING
HOME.
>> WHY HAVEN'T YOU BOUGHT A NEW
CAR?
>> CAN'T AFFORD IT.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD IT.
PRICES ARE TOO HIGH, INTEREST
RATES ARE TOO HIGH.
>> NOW HIS WIFE IS PREGNANT.
WOULD YOU PUT YOUR BABY IN THIS
CAR?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> SO OUTRUNNING THE MARKET MAY
PROVE IMPOSSIBLE.
>> WE JUST WANT A SAFE FAMILY
CAR THAT CAN GET US AROUND TOWN.
WHEN IS THIS GOING TO COME BACK
TO EARTH?
>> AND JAKE, THAT'S THE QUESTION
SO MANY AMERICANS ARE ASKING.
AND AS PRICES KEEP CLIMBING AND
THE COST OF PAYING OFF THAT DEBT
KEEPS GOING UP AS WELL, IT'S
GOING TO BECOME THAT MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT FOR FAMILIES TO HAVE A
FINANCIAL PLAN MONTH TO MONTH
JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
>> GABE COHEN BRINGING US THE
HUMAN COST OF THIS.
>> JOINING US TO DISCUSS,
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY
OF CONNECTICUT.
HE'S ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
YOU JUST HEARD ONE MAN TALKING
ABOUT HOW HE CAN'T AFFORD A SAFE
CAR FOR HIS FAMILY.
A WOMAN TALKING ABOUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD A HOUSE BECAUSE
OF THESE SKYROCKETING MORTGAGE
RATES.
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO NOT JUST
YOUR CONSTITUENTS BUT ALL
AMERICANS WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WHO ARE NOW GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ANOTHER RATE
HIKE?
>> I THINK YOUR POINT THERE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
AMERICANS WERE STRUGGLING BEFORE
THIS RATE HIKE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE STRUGGLING
AFTER IT.
AND WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE FOR
MOST AMERICANS OUT THERE WHO ARE
EARNING $30,000, $50,000 A YEAR,
THEY HAVE BEEN LIVING IN CRISIS
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK, UNABLE TO
KEEP UP WITH BILLS FOR YEARS.
AND SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS THESE
STRUCTURAL UNFAIRNESS IN THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY THAT ALLOWS IT
TO DO SO WELL FOR THE CEOs AND
FOR THE BILLIONAIRES AND
MILLIONAIRES AND UNDERMINES
SECURITY FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES.
SO THIS RATE HIKE IS NECESSARY,
ACCORDING TO THE FED, IN ORDER
TO COOL WHAT YOUR OWN REPORTER
SAYS IS WHITE HOT, RED HOT
DEMAND IN A 3.6% UNEMPLOYMENT
ECONOMY.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER REMINDER OF
WHY WE NEED TO TAKE A BIG STEP
BACK AND FIGURE OUT WHY FOR SO
LONG ORDINARY AMERICANS WHO ARE
WORKING FOR A LIVING AND GETTING
SCREWED AND THE FOLKS AT THE
VERY TOP OF THE ECONOMY, NO
MATTER WHETHER WE'RE IN AN ERA
OF ECONOMIC EXPANSION OR
CONTRACTION, SEEM TO DO JUST
FINE.
I KNOW I'M A BROKEN RECORD ON
THIS, BUT THERE'S SOMETHING
PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD DO TO
BRING THE COST OF LIVING DOWN
FOR AMERICANS.
THAT'S TO GET RID OF THE TRUMP
CHINA TARIFFS.
THAT WOULD BRING PRICES DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY, SAVING FAMILIES
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
I KNOW PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
WORRIED ABOUT THE IMPACT THIS
COULD HAVE ON UNION MEMBERS.
DO YOU WANT PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
LIFT THESE TARIFFS?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU HAVE TO
JUDGE THE SHORT TERM IMPACT OF
THAT VERSUS THE LONG TERM IMPACT
OF REBUILDING AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING.
THAT WILL DELIVER GOOD PAYING
JOBS TO AMERICAN CITIZENS.
ULTIMATELY, WE GOT INTO THIS
POSITION BECAUSE WE DIT
OUTSOURCE MILLIONS OF JOBS TO
COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA.
WE LOST THAT BLUE COLLAR ERA
ARISTOCRACY THAT WAS MAKING IT
POSSIBLE TO PUT KIDS THROUGH
COLLEGE.
TO HAVE A TRADE POLICY THAT
EFFECTUATES THAT, IS THE
SOLUTION TO THE COST CRISIS AND
THE WAGE CRISIS THAT CONFRONTS A
LOT OF AMERICANS.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
INSTITUTIONAL RE-EXAMINATION OF
THE ECONOMY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT A SHORT TERM
RELIEF FOR INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES.
GET RID OF THE TRUMP CHINA
TARIFFS.
I DON'T THINK YOU SUPPORTED THEM
TO BEGIN WITH.
YOU GET RID OF THEM, AND I HAVE
SEEN FRED HOTPERG UNDER OBAMA
SAYING IT COULD BRING DOWN
PRICES $500 TO $1,000 A FAMILY.
THERE'S A SOLUTION THAT WOULD
HELP AMERICANS RIGHT NOW.
>> BUT YOU'RE ALSO SEEING THE
BEGINNING OF THIS RESHORING OF
JOBS THAT HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN
MOVED OVER TO PLACES LIKE CHINA.
SO YOU ARE RIGHT THAT I DIDN'T
SUPPORT EVERY ASPECT OF THE
TRUMP TARIFF PLAN, BUT I DO
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT WE SHOULD
USE TRADE POLICY INCLUDING
TARIFFS TO TRY TO HAVE LONG TERM
GROWTH OF MANUFACTURING JOBS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE SHORT TERM
SOLUTION?
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE WHITE
HOUSE, THE SENATE, THE HOUSE.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT YOUR
PARTY CAN DO?
YOU CONTROL GOVERNMENT NOW.
IS THERE SOMETHING YOU CAN DO
RIGHT NOW TO HELP STRUGGLING
AMERICANS WHO ARE NOW BEING
ASKED TO SOLVE THE INFLATION
PROBLEM BY HAVING TO PAY MORE IN
CREDIT CARD DEBT?
>> WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT NEXT
WEEK.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A BILL
THAT'S GOING TO DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE HEALTH CARE COSTS FOR
AMERICAN CONSUMERS AND IN
PARTICULAR FIXED INCOME SENIORS
WHO ARE OFTEN THE HARDEST HIT,
LIKE IN MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
NOT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN WILL
JOIN US, AS WE TRY TO TRIM THE
COST OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
BUT